(cris de la foule)
rappellent une autre époque,
celles de la Révolution de 201
et du Printemps arabe.esesesese)
Des dizaines de pers, , , , , ,s
dont certains membres
de la presse, pourtant
bien identifiables.
Depuis 2011, le 14 janvier
est un jour de commémorationi ie
le départ du dictateur Ben Ali.
Mais cette année c c c c c c c e
officiel. Il a imposé
un couvre-feu deux jours avant
et interdit les manifestations.
Officiellement,
à cause de la pandémie.SeSeSeSe,
1200 manifestants ont défié
l'interdiction.
"Ils étaient bien plus
uxuxuxuxux" selon Chaïma Issa,
membre d'une coalition
de citoyens qui s'opposeededede.
- Donc déjà, j'ai pris un coup
de matJ'J'J'J'J'J'J'J'J'J'J'J'Jà
hospitalisé parce qu'ils doivent
faire une opération sur son. . ,
ce qu'on a vu, on ne l'a pas vu
années, et aussi, même Ben Ali
n'a pas utilisé tante,e,e,e,e,
dans les manifestations.
- Comme des milliers d'autres
tunisiens, cette militante
s'oppocececececececececececececa
concentré une grande partie
du pouvoir politique tunisien
entre ses mains.
- Aujourd'hui, Kaïs Saïed,
avec son coup d'État, il est en
train de nier toesesesesesest en
train de gommer notre démocrati.
de commémorer cette fête
deononononononon qui a été
confisquée par le président
de manière unilatérale de
supprimer ce jour qui était,
précédemment un jour deerererer,
le président Saïed a limogé
le Parlement tunisien
et entrepris de
par décret avec un petit
groupe de collaborateurs.
Il juge que le pays est devenu
ingoeseseseseseses partis
d'opposition sont furieux,araras
du parti islamiste, Ennahdha.
SAIDA OUNISSI, député
et p-p du parti Ennahdha
prend des décisions de manière
unilatérale, promulgue
des décrets présidentiels
et gouverne aujourd'hui
du Palais de Carthage.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Onze ans après, les Tunisiens
attendent toujours de récolter
La vie est dure, l'économie, au
bord du gouffre. La population,
les syndicats et certains partis
d'opposition avaient donc
d'abord appuyé la démarche
en espérant un déblocage
de la situation, mais ces ap
s'effritent.
MOHAMED IMED TORJEMANE,
- Ce n'est pas un secret que
les Tunisiens so
Il y avait des ambitions,
il y avait des attentes,
mais malheureusement,
n'ont pas trouvé un chemin
pour la concrétisation
Le train de la démoc
en Tunisie est toujours surs s .
- Deva
internationale, le président
tunisien a lancé une vaste
un référendum sur des
tititititititititititutionnels
est prévu en juillet et
des élections générales
suivront en décembre.
Problème : la participat
n'est pas acquise.
- Nous allons boycotter ces...
de théâtre qui sont jouéesueueur
le régime de Kaïs Saïed.
- Ma crainte, c'est que
l l l l l l l l l les Tunisiens
perdent l'espoir ou perdent
leur confiance en la démocra
et le rend2,2,2,2,2,2,2,2,2,2,2,
coynynynynynynynynynynynynynynye
évidemment positive et porteuse
pour notre pays qui
lentntntntntntntntntntnts réclat
un réel dialogue national
pour résoudre cette crise.
la population au programmesisisa
la suite des choses.